from George of the Jungle to the whale
Brendan Fraser had quite the career but
do you know exactly how he's become the
comeback King let's get into it how many
of you remember that theme song George
George of the Jungle strong yes he can
be that's right we're talking about the
1997 Disney live action film George of
the Jungle or the role that truly turned
Brendan Fraser into a household name it
got mixed reviews from critics but
audiences loved it helping it to bring
in 170 million against a 55 million
budget as a Tarzan spoof based on the
animated series from the 1960s Brendan's
wardrobe really wasn't much more than a
loincloth and he recalls how he was
waxed and starved of carbohydrates for
the role it even got so bad that could
not remember my PIN number his brain was
misfiring so bad that it just wasn't
coming to him